hello in the next and the last
presentation we we kind of redefine the
sine the cosine and the tangent
functions in a broader way where we said
if we have a unit circle and we define
and we have and our theta is or our
angle is let me use the right tool let's
say and our angle is the angle between
say the x-axis and a radius in the unit
circle and this is our radius well and
this and the point the coordinate of the
point where this radius intersects the
unit circle is X comma Y our new
definition of the trig functions was
that sine of theta is equal to the
y-coordinate right this is the
y-coordinate where it intersects the
unit circle and remember this is the
unit circle it's not just any circle
which means it has a radius of 1 cosine
of theta cosine of theta is equal to the
x-coordinate of this point
right this is the x-coordinate and
tangent of theta equals opposite over
adjacent or Y over X equal to Y over X
and that's interesting because that's
also equal to sine of theta over cosine
of theta I'll just do that out I wasn't
even planning on covering that but just
it leaves you something to think about
so with that said let's take a look or
let's try to see how this defines the
sine of these functions and I guess a
good place to start is just with the the
sine function and we can try to graph it
so let's write let's do a little table
like we always do when we define a
function let's put in values of theta
and let's figure out what sine of theta
is
so when theta is equal to zero radians
what is sine of theta so when theta is
zero right then the radius that it's the
radius between it but the theta this
this is the radius and this is the point
where the radius intersects the unit
circle and this point has a coordinate
one comma zero right because we and so
if where it intersects the unit circle
is at 1 comma 0
then sine of theta is just the
y-coordinate so the sine of theta is 0
if we said what is what is sine of theta
when theta is equal to PI over 2 PI over
2 so now our radius is this radius and
we intersect the unit circle right here
at the point 0 comma 1 and what's the
y-coordinate at 0 comma 1 what's 1 what
happens when we have theta is equal to
pi radians so at PI radians we intersect
the unit circle right here right we're
at PI radians this is the angle PI pi
radians we intersect the unit circle at
negative 1 comma 0 right because it's
once again this is the unit circle so
negative 1 comma 0 what's the
y-coordinate well it's it's zero so sine
of pi is equal to 0 let's just keep
going around the circle when we have the
angle when theta is equal to 3 PI over
over 4 right because it's oh no sorry 3
PI over 2 right because this is PI and
this is another 1/2 pi right so this is
2 PI over 2 sorry so when theta is equal
to 3 PI over 2 what is sine of theta
well now we intersect the unit circle
down here at the point 0 comma negative
1 so now sine of theta is equal to
negative 1
and then if we go all the way around the
circle to 2 pi radians
we're back at this point again so sine
of theta so when we have we're two pi
sine of theta is now zero once again so
let's graph these points out and then
we'll try to figure out what the points
in between look like and I'll show you
what a the graph of a sine function is
let's see so let's draw the x axis this
is my x axis and let's draw the y axis
not as clean as I wanted to draw this
this is why why and that's X but in this
case instead of saying that's the x axis
is called that the theta axis because we
defined theta as the input or our
domains in terms of theta so theta this
is the theta axis and now we're going to
graph sine of theta so we said when
theta equals zero sine of theta is equal
to zero so that's this point right here
is zero comma zero when theta is equal
to when theta is equal to PI over 2 sine
of theta is equal to 1 so this is the
point PI over 2 comma 1 right that's
just this one when theta is equal to PI
when theta is equal to PI sine of theta
is 0 again so this is the point PI comma
0 and when theta equals 3 PI over 2 let
me write that 3 PI over 2 I'll write 3
PI over 2 what was sine of theta N
equals negative 1 interesting
and then when we got to 2pi we've got to
theta equal to 2pi sine of theta again
equals zero so we know that these points
are on the graph of sine of theta and if
you actually tried the points in between
and I and I as an exercise it might be
interesting for you to do so either you
could actually figure out a lot of the
points using 30-60-90 triangles or or
using the Pythagorean theorem but you
actually get a curve that looks
something let me use a nicer color than
this kind of drab gray you get a graph
that looks something like this and
you've probably seen that before if you
ever it looks like a I mean people the
term for this function is actually a
sine wave it looks like a something
that's oscillating or that's moving up
and down and actually if you were to
keep if you were to put in Thetas that
were less than zero
the sine wave will keep going into the
negative theta axis and it keeps going
forever in both directions it keeps
oscillating between 1 and negative 1 and
the points in between so that's the
graph of the sine function in the next
module I'll actually do the graph of the
cosine function or actually I might just
show you the graph of the cosine
function and then I'll show you how they
relate and and and how these can
describe any kind of or many types of
oscillatory I guess of things in the
world and and how it relates to
frequency and amplitude so I'll see you
the next module and and just for fun you
might want to sit down with some piece
with a piece of paper and try to graph
the cosine function or the tangent
function as well have fun